the human mind is complicated but do you
like to think of it as like a bucket
that gets refilled for introverts in
terms of energy of
um
social interaction that that that
they're
able to uh handle is do you think of it
like that
as a bucket that gets emptied and needs
to be refilled i think of it yeah more
or less because i use the metaphor of a
battery that gets recharged or not it's
basically the same thing different
metaphor um but yeah but just to add on
that that there is a layer of complexity
to that because
you could be somebody who
doesn't want the kind of social life
let's say where you have to be like on
and presenting and interacting with tons
of people all the time but you'd get
really lonely if you were just by
yourself you know so what you want is to
maybe be in the company of a couple
people you know really well
like for me the pandemic was not
actually that hard for me personally i
mean i i lost family but i mean from the
point of view of what we're talking
about it wasn't that hard because i live
with my husband and my kids
so i knew it was hard on the kids and i
felt badly for them but for me i was
like
you know what i kind of i have a lot of
social life right here in the house
and i can focus and do my work
yeah
that's the cool thing about that
pandemic i think it helped people figure
out how much they love their family i
think that's true um and and allow you
give you a chance to really reconnect
with kids
uh with your kids like really spend time
with them it's just fascinating to watch
like people actually it did strengthen
the family unit in a often beautiful
way
which just sucks to me too to have to
leave behind at this point yeah and i
think that's part of what people are not
going to want to go back to that we need
to solve for um to the extent that work
becomes non-remote again
yeah i think people have just realized
how precious those aspects of their
lives are and you know for somebody
who's in a
sort of conventional office job where
you're going home and seeing your kids
for an hour before bedtime and that's
your interaction with them
that's
that's kind of a ridiculous way to set
things up it's cool that you can get i
think a lot of places give you the
option now which is interesting you get
to optimize that element of your life
you take the commute and the office work
and then the social interaction there or
do you focus on the work at home
it's also lonely at home but then you
get to see your kids if you have kids
that's part of the optimization is like
i have some options now and i'm going to
try to optimize
solitude
loneliness happiness productivity
seeing family
uh
seeing co-workers
the chemistry with the team building
with the co-workers versus just the raw
uh exchange of information with the
co-workers it's fascinating to see how
that how that kind of evolves yeah and
then there's the big the third space
idea of you know the spaces where you're
um in a co-working space or a cafe or
something like that you've got other
people around you but you're not exactly
interacting with them but they're very
much there
and that's huge too
we i don't think we think about that
enough
yeah that energy is there
yeah yeah i i lived in manhattan for 17
years um before we had kids
and
i absolutely loved it like i loved it
the feeling of all that energy all
around you but you could be anonymous
within it to me it was perfect
you